once these cuts take effect thousands of
teachers and educators will be laid off
air traffic controllers and airport
security will see cutbacks these cuts
will setback medical science for a
generation to hear President Obama
telling the impending 85 billion dollars
in spending cuts to the federal budget
known as the sequester are the worst
disaster since Seth MacFarlane hosted
the Academy Awards but before you dive
deep into depression here are five facts
that should take the sting out of the
sequester these cuts don't have to
happen the actual cuts in fiscal year
2013 are only 44 billion dollars
according to the Congressional Budget
Office the rest don't even take place
until 2014 or later and whether you're
used forty four billion dollars or
eighty five billion dollars we're
talking about one or two percent of
total government spending these cuts
don't have to happen even with the
sequester the federal government is
expected to spend more this year than it
did last year these cuts don't have to
happen the largest chunk of cuts will
come out of the defense budget which is
doubled over the past decade the
Pentagon will still have about 500
billion dollars at its disposal not
counting more related and emergency
appropriations these cuts don't have to
happen the White House's Office of
Management budget says the sequester
will cut a whopping two million dollars
from the 20 million dollar budget for
the National Drug Intelligence Center
that sounds pretty bad until you realize
that drug intelligence center closed its
doors in June 2012 these cuts don't have
to happen
the whole damn sequester was the Obama
administration's idea as the Washington
Post Bob Woodward has reported despite
Obama's denials to the contrary the
automatic spending cuts were initiated
by the White House as part of the deal
to raise the debt limit back in August
2011
so as members of the president's cabinet
and party rail against the draconian
nature of the sequester and the
unfairness of it all it
worth keeping in mind that these cuts
are genuinely puny and that the
president has nobody to blame but
himself for reason TV I'm Nicolas